what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and man i still can't get over that loki
finale it was truly incredible and now
the multiverse is here and don't worry
that's all i'm gonna say about the
finale if you haven't seen it yet no
spoilers here but as we all pretty much
assumed and guessed from the very
beginning the multiverse is now here
loki brought into the mcu the multiverse
we are now living in a
marvel cinematic multiverse and things
are really about to change and
get pretty crazy as far as the
multiverse is concerned spider-man noah
home is next and then of course
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is going to be truly insane but
let's not forget that marvel still is
going to remain
somewhat grounded there are going to be
different aspects of the mcu moving
forward
different sides one is going to be an
absolutely insane
multiverse side the other will be a
grounded side like the falcon and the
winter soldier and then we're going to
have a
space side like thor love and thunder
guardians of the galaxy 3 captain marvel
2
just a bunch of different awesome sides
of the mcu
but there is one extremely exciting part
about the grounded mcu that is coming
relatively soon as well and that is the
thunderbolts
slash the dark avengers we actually have
a confirmation from marvel studios as
president kevin feige that
the thunderbolts or the dark avengers
are being assembled right now
one particular character in the mcu
right now has started recruiting
these members and this is coming right
from the big dog himself
kevin feige so this is official so
that's what i'll be breaking down in
this video that report and i'll be
talking about how
there is a mutant in the mcu that
debuted in black widow and according to
the actor himself
he is indeed the first mutant and don't
worry if you're worried about spoilers
for black widow it
really isn't a spoiler at all but if you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so recently over at d23 inside the
disney podcast
kevin feige was on deck to answer some
questions and these questions were about
a very specific character
and what exactly she's doing right now
most of you know who i'm talking about
julia louise dreyfus's valentina who
first appeared in the falcon and the
winter soldier
and at the end of the falcon and the
winter soldier as she was talking to
john walker and his wife
it certainly did look like she was doing
something aka recruiting people for
a certain team and this is what kevin
feige was asked
about that something that she's doing
and this is what he had to say
and actually i lied we are going to be
talking about spoilers for
the black widow post credits scene now i
won't talk about the entirety of the
post credit scene
what i'm gonna say really isn't that big
of a spoiler especially if you've
already seen the falcon in the winter
soldier ending so not that big of a deal
but watch at your own risk
but in regards to valentina popping back
up in the black widow post-credits scene
speaking to elena and doing something as
we're talking about this is what he had
to say
she's doing something yes she is she
seems to be
in recruitment mode does yelena already
work for her
they seem to have a connection at that
point yes
so big confirmation right here from
kevin feige himself
yes valentina is recruiting for her own
team
and as it seems she's actually already
very well
in the process of recruiting and has
already recruited people because
remember
black widow actually takes place before
the falcon and the winter soldier
now the post credit scene itself may
take place after
the falcon and the winter soldier
however yelena seems to already be
working for val
yelena states that she's not supposed to
be contacting her while she's on holiday
holiday meaning she's on vacation from
working for val
and this is what kevin feige just
confirmed he says does yelena already
work for her
they seem to have a connection at that
point yes that's an exact quote from
kevin feige
so valentina has recruited yelena on her
team and now she has recruited
us agent john walker and of course kevin
feige stated that she is going to
continue to show up in the mcu and is
going to play a very important role
he went on to say and the future is
bright for the mcu because
julia is in it we are gigantic fans of
hers at marvel we had a general meeting
with her many years ago
luis diaz pacito and i really just
geeked out that we were even meeting her
because she's such an icon
and we're very big seinfeld nerds at
marvel studios as they should be but he
continued to say
so the notion of bringing her into the
world was always something
if we could find the right thing was
something we wanted to do
and when this role came about and the
opportunity to have her
in black widow and the falcon and the
winter soldier and maybe
in some other things coming up which i
actually find very funny because kevin
feige is
the vault he never gives away any
spoilers even when it is just so
obvious he still never caves he's never
going to be the person that tells you in
fact i'm actually really surprised that
he told us that valentina is recruiting
a team
now that one has basically already been
stated she's recruited two people
already we've witnessed this on screen
but i'm still surprised he even said
that but when he says
maybe some other things coming up we
already know that she is definitely
going to be
in some other things coming up and he
confirms this with his final statement
when he says
she was totally on board and really into
it so it's an amazing addition to the
world
and i look forward to people being
surprised by just
where she'll show up next so boom
there's your confirmation she's going to
show up again we're going to see her
recruit other people for
either the thunderbolts or the dark
avengers at this point in time it's
really unclear what team exactly she's
forming there's still somewhat of a
mystery surrounding her we don't know
who
exactly she works for but she does seem
to work for the government there's a lot
of things that she knows that only
government
officials would know she tells jon
here's a little secret to know about
captain america shield
it doesn't really belong to the
government it's kind of a gray area
and in the comics she does originally
work for shield that is until
basically betraying them and becomes
madame hydra so right now even though
she's a mystery it does seem like she
works for the government
this could point to the dark avengers
being formed after all the government
doesn't really have an avengers team
right now and before avengers infinity
war and avengers end game it seemed like
the government specifically
thunderbolt ross really wanted to
control the superhero group
that's what the sokovia accords were
really about so perhaps valentino works
for ross and she's recruiting his dark
avengers team for him but on the other
hand
she does seem to be operating as she
says within a gray area and it seems
like she is definitely the one that does
things that aren't exactly
legal so therefore a non-official
government team
is something that she could be putting
together which could be the thunderbolts
especially since she has recruited
us agent john walker for that the
government essentially already said that
john walker
is not a part of their government at
least publicly he's no longer in the
army and was basically forbidden to take
on the flag smashers so the government
isn't about to let him be on some public
avengers team
and the same actually goes for elena
bulova she was a black widow
working for drakov they're not exactly
going to want her on a public avengers
team either and it seems like the other
person that is going to be a part of
will say the thunderbolts is going to be
zemo
at the end of the falcon and the winter
soldiers scene with u.s agent valentina
refers to
zemo as her friend and if it is the
thunderbolts team and it's going to be
controlled by
thunderbolt ross well right now zemo is
in the raft
the high security prison in the middle
of the ocean that thunderbolt ross
actually controls
so it won't be too hard to get him onto
the team so basically based off of the
characters that we already know to be a
part of this team it does seem like it's
more along the lines of the thunderbolts
being formed
rather than the dark avengers however
definitely don't take the dark avengers
team off the table
but either way it has been confirmed by
kevin feige that a new team is
being recruited as we speak and
valentina will pop
up more in the future most likely to
continue to recruit her team of dark
avengers or
thunderbolts which is super exciting now
the last thing i want to talk about in
this video is what i mentioned in the
beginning and that is apparently we have
our first
mutant in the mcu the actor daniel
richards aka the dutch giant who played
a person
by the name of ursa in black widow a
prison inmate of david harbors the red
guardians
recently posted to instagram saying
marvel black widow is out after two
years i can finally tell who my
character is
ursa major mutant x-men that appears in
the marvel cinematic universe ursa is
part of the winter guard
noted for being russia's answer to the
avengers
his power transforms him into an
incredible bear
transcending the hulk and size ursa
appears many times in the comics
fighting wolverine and the hulk when
production on set told me who i really
was in black widow i let some tears in
my hotel room
because my movie dream became true being
a official comic superhero i can only
hope marva will bring back ursa
in full form now in the movie he is
called ursa and
red guardian does call him a big bear
before the movie came out david arbour
also posted to his instagram stating
that the winter guard
says hello and he did actually mention
the winter guards characters by name and
ursa was one of those characters
and at first i thought that well maybe
this actor is simply saying that that's
who he is but
he does state that the production team
told him who he was
so technically this is the first mutant
in the marvel cinematic universe now
unfortunately to the normal public
they're not really going to know this
only us super fans are going to know
this
so it is not yet a public declaration
that the mutants are indeed in the mcu
but
we know they are now in the mcu they are
coming in future films
and it's only a matter of time until
they are finally addressed as what they
are mutants and then of course the x-men
so
huge news today we have mutants in the
mcu
and the thunderbolts or the dark
avengers are starting to get recruited
in the mcu and the team is going to be
out there soon let me know what you
think about this awesome news in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof